Just a quick note. This episode is a little on the crude side. Nothing too terrible, but if you have small kids, you might want to listen to this one first before you let them listen to it. Just to check it out. Alright, thanks. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There was a rubber shortage in the US during World War II because we were fighting Japan in many of the countries that supplied our rubber. So the government funded research into synthetic rubber to make up the shortfall. One of the products of this research was a new material made by mixing boric acid and silicone oil.
先提个醒。这一集的内容稍微有点粗俗。虽然没什么太糟糕的，但如果你有小孩，在让他们听之前，你可能想先自己听一遍。就当是先审核一下。好了，谢谢。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。二战期间，美国出现了橡胶短缺，因为我们当时在许多供应橡胶的国家与日本交战。因此，政府资助了合成橡胶的研究以弥补缺口。这项研究的产品之一是一种通过混合硼酸和硅油制成的新材料。
It could bounce and it could stretch. You know, it was rubbery, but sadly, it could not be used to make tires or rafts or gas masks. It had no practical use at all. But a marketing consultant discovered that it was pretty fun to play with, so he put it in tiny plastic eggs and sold it as silly putty. Hey! Hey! It's silly bunny. Hey! Hey!
它能弹跳，也能拉伸。你知道，它很有弹性，但遗憾的是，它不能用来制造轮胎、木筏或防毒面具。它完全没有任何实际用途。但一位营销顾问发现它玩起来很有趣，于是把它装进小塑料蛋里，作为“傻瓜油灰”（Silly Putty）出售。嘿！嘿！是傻瓜兔。嘿！嘿！
It's silly bunny time! Yes, there are hours and hours of fun and the little egg that silly bunny comes in. We're surrounded by products that were designed for one purpose but found their true calling in another line of work. That is Amy Standin' co-host and co-creator of the new KQED podcast, The Leap. Plato was invented to clean coal sit off of walls. Both Viagra and Rogan were designed to lower blood pressure, before they found their real purpose, making boners and growing hair.
是傻瓜兔时间！没错，傻瓜兔装在小蛋里，能带来无穷无尽的乐趣。我们周围到处都是那些最初为了一个目的而设计，却在另一个领域找到了真正使命的产品。那是艾米·斯坦丁，KQED新播客《飞跃》（The Leap）的联合主持人和联合创作者。培乐多（Play-Doh）最初是用来清理墙上煤灰的。伟哥和落健（Rogaine）在找到它们真正的用途——助勃和生发——之前，最初都是为了降低血压而设计的。
In all of these cases, the original designs were meant to solve big, important problems, but they had to settle for less meaningful, yet, you know, maybe slightly more delightful roles in the world. But in rare cases, the story goes the other way, and something designed to be a trifle, a gag, a joke, stumbles upon its true destiny as something heroic and honorable. Ladies and gentlemen, may I introduce you to the heroic and honorable product known as Liquid As. Liquid As is a bottled smell, and as you could probably guess, it does not smell good. That's an understatement.
在所有这些案例中，最初的设计都是为了解决重大而重要的问题，但它们不得不退而求其次，在世界上扮演一些不那么重要，但可能稍微更令人愉悦的角色。但在极少数情况下，故事的发展方向恰恰相反，一些被设计成琐事、恶作剧或笑话的东西，却意外地发现了它作为英雄和光荣之物的真正命运。女士们先生们，请允许我向你们介绍这种被称为“液体屁”（Liquid Ass）的英雄而光荣的产品。液体屁是一种瓶装气味，正如你可能猜到的那样，它闻起来并不好。这还是轻描淡写的说法。
It's important that you get how bad this smell is. It's kind of the linchpin to this whole story. So while I was reporting this, I made a bunch of people in my life smell liquid ass. Oh, my throat's constricting. It's super real. Do you feel like there's a sense of shame associated with that smell? Yeah, like you feel like you shouldn't know what that smells like. Exactly. That you do.
让你明白这种气味有多糟糕很重要。这几乎是整个故事的关键。所以在我报道这件事时，我让生活中的一群人闻了闻液体屁。哦，我的喉咙在收缩。这太真实了。你觉得这种气味会让人产生一种羞耻感吗？是的，就像你觉得你不应该知道那是什么味道一样。没错。而你却知道了。
No! This terrible smell was invented by a guy named Alan Whitman. As a teenager, Alan's main interest was pranks, specifically smell-related pranks. There was one with Lindberger cheese, something else he called the ketchup situation. But it wasn't until he began experimenting with a chemistry set his parents gave him that he'd create his masterwork. He's cagey when asked what exactly the ingredients were, but he is very comfortable describing how it smells.
不！这种可怕的气味是由一个叫艾伦·惠特曼的人发明的。十几岁时，艾伦的主要兴趣是恶作剧，特别是与气味有关的恶作剧。有一个是用林堡干酪做的，还有另一个他称之为“番茄酱事件”的东西。但直到他开始用父母给他的化学套装进行实验时，他才创造了他的杰作。当被问及具体成分是什么时，他守口如瓶，但他非常乐意描述它闻起来是什么样子的。
It smells like ass. It's a butt crack, you know, kind of a sore smell with a little head of some dead animal in there. Butt crack with a hint of dead animal. For 15 years, liquid ass languished in smell obscurity. Ellen would use it to pull the occasional prank, but it never found a larger audience. And then, when he and his friend Andrew Masters lost their jobs at a trucking company, they decided to turn this terrible smell into an income.
它闻起来像屁。你知道，那是股屁股缝的味道，一种酸痛的味道，里面还带着一点死动物的头。屁股缝的味道加上一点死动物的气息。15年来，液体屁在气味界默默无闻。艾伦偶尔会用它来搞恶作剧，但它从未找到更大的受众。后来，当他和朋友安德鲁·马斯特斯在一家货运公司失业后，他们决定把这种可怕的气味变成收入来源。
Andro now and didn't even have to advertise Liquid Asks. Radio talk shows did it for them. If you ever see a bottle of liquid Asks, Yes, Bob of the Slough Spongebob works here uses liquid ass it's awful shit man liquid ass that's how it's turned it smells it's now the opian anthony show the pony tail i think i just washed my hair the orders poured in you can probably imagine the clientele
安德鲁现在甚至不需要为“液体屁”做广告。电台脱口秀节目为他们做了。如果你曾经见过一瓶“液体屁”，是的，鲍勃在这里工作，他用了液体屁，这真是太糟糕了，伙计，液体屁，这就是它转化的方式，它闻起来，现在是奥皮和安东尼秀，马尾辫，我想我刚洗了头，订单蜂拥而至，你大概能想象出客户群是谁。
teenage boys playing extremely stupid pranks. But then, 23 years after its invention, liquidats found a higher calling. Enter Stu Segal. Segal produced a bunch of television shows in the 90s. Including the show's Hunter, Renegade, and Silk Stockings. a cop and good at his job, but he committed the ultimate sin and testified against other cops gone bad. And silk stockings. Silk stockings was one of those shows you might have watched on the USA Network when the people you were babysitting for didn't have HBO.
那是些搞极其愚蠢恶作剧的十几岁男孩。但后来，在它发明23年后，液体屁找到了更高的使命。斯图·西格尔登场了。西格尔在90年代制作了一堆电视节目。包括《猎人》、《叛逆悍将》和《丝袜》。一个警察，工作出色，但他犯了终极罪行，指证了其他变坏的警察。还有《丝袜》。《丝袜》是你可能在USA电视网看过的节目之一，当时你帮人看管的孩子家里没有HBO。
Stoos business was thriving until right about September 11th, 2001. My business changed after 9-11 because the networks wanted to get away from violence. They wanted to get away from shooting things and blowing stuff up and Yeah, it was a dramatic change. It flat-line my business for quite a while. One day we were in the thick of making television and the next day we weren't All those sets he'd built were just sitting there, gathering dust. But it gave him an idea for a whole new business venture. Maybe cops who needed training could get some use out of those old sets.
斯图的生意一直很兴隆，直到2001年9月11日前后。我的生意在911之后变了，因为电视网想远离暴力。他们想远离枪战和爆炸，是的，这是一个巨大的变化。它让我的生意停滞了很长一段时间。前一天我们还沉浸在制作电视节目中，第二天我们就没活干了。他建造的所有布景都闲置在那里，积满灰尘。但这给了他一个全新商业冒险的灵感。也许需要训练的警察可以利用那些旧布景。
We did quite a bit of training on that kind of front. Like how best to respond to a school shooting or how to carry out a drug bust, where to position the officers, how to break down a door. This was good business, and then in 2003, the U.S. invaded Iraq. Reservous for being called up to go overseas. And a lot of them stew already knew, because these were the same people, cops, mainly, who'd been training on his sets. One day, he, come on over.
我们在那方面做了相当多的训练。比如如何最好地应对校园枪击案，或者如何执行毒品搜查，警察该站在哪里，如何破门。这生意不错，然后到了2003年，美国入侵伊拉克。预备役人员被征召去海外。其中很多人斯图已经认识了，因为他们就是那些在这些布景上训练的警察。有一天，他，过来吧。
So that's how it started. Stu's big idea was that he could use not just the sets, but the whole lineup of Hollywood effects to create a facsimile of combat. Show soldiers exactly what they were stepping into. He says no one else was doing this. 18 and 19 year olds were being sent to Iraq with almost no sense of how the place would look,
事情就是这样开始的。斯图的宏大构想是，他不仅可以使用布景，还可以利用整套好莱坞特效来创造一个战斗的模拟场景。向士兵展示他们即将踏入的地方。他说没有其他人这样做。18和19岁的年轻人被派往伊拉克，几乎不知道那个地方看起来是什么样子，
what the culture was like, or how to communicate with people. All their training was pretty much sterile, or make believe this is that, or they would take the Marines and turn their shirts inside out and say, okay, those are the bad guys. You know, that's not training. It's not realistic training. Stoos has the military has gotten a lot better at training since then. But in the beginning, his innovation was to try and make trainees forget that they were on a TV set in Southern California.
文化是什么样的，或者如何与人交流。他们所有的训练几乎都是枯燥的，或者是假装这是什么，或者他们会带上海军陆战队员，把他们的衬衫反穿，说，好吧，那些是坏人。你知道，那不是训练。那不是现实的训练。斯图说，从那以后，军队在训练方面已经进步了很多。但在最初，他的创新是试图让受训者忘记他们是在南加州的一个电视布景上。
His sets should look and feel as much as possible. Like the kind of place a group of Marines might go out and patrol in Iraq. We're in a simulated Iraqi village. Stu got one of his employees, Greg Figueroa, to show me around. Up on this tower here, we'll have two huge speakers playing called a prayer. Greg figure out to show me around. In a simulation, this whole place would be full of actors.
他的布景应该尽可能看起来和感觉起来像海军陆战队在伊拉克巡逻时可能会去的地方。我们现在在一个模拟的伊拉克村庄里。斯图让他的一名员工格雷格·菲格罗亚带我参观。在这个塔楼上，我们会放两个巨大的扬声器播放祈祷声。格雷格·菲格罗亚带我参观。在模拟中，整个地方都会挤满演员。
Actual Iraqis who live in San Diego and now get hired as extras to act like Iraqis. The village has a complete fake Iraqi marketplace. Bins of plastic cucumbers and yams stand selling dusty old Sony disc man's and clock radios. Greg and others here work very hard to make this place look realistic. And Greg can do this because he did two tours in Iraq, as a medic in 2007 and in 2008. And he remembers exactly what it felt like to walk into a village like this, how unwelcome he felt there, and how much the Iraqis wanted him to go away. These people are just trying to live their lives and now we set up this base right outside their village.
住在圣地亚哥的真正的伊拉克人，现在被雇为临时演员来扮演伊拉克人。这个村庄有一个完整的假伊拉克市场。装满塑料黄瓜和山药的箱子，卖着尘土飞扬的旧索尼随身听和收音机。格雷格和其他人在这里非常努力地让这个地方看起来真实。格雷格能做到这一点，因为他在2007年和2008年作为医务兵在伊拉克服役了两次。他清楚地记得走进这样一个村庄的感觉，他在那里感到多么不受欢迎，伊拉克人多么希望他离开。这些人只是想过自己的生活，而我们却在他们的村庄外建立了这个基地。
So in a simulation, the whole place is supposed to feel on edge, like anything could happen, and then it does. Meanwhile, sometimes they'll pipe in the sound of a scene from saving private Ryan. Just to amp things up a bit. You can talk about it intellectually beforehand, but once the gunfire goes and people are screaming and yelling, you know, all the things that happen, it is real. Except nobody dies and nobody bleeds out and we can do it again. Stoo says he seen recruits wet their pants even throw up in these simulations. Both normal reactions to the screaming, the smoke, the explosions, the disorientation of it all.
所以在模拟中，整个地方都应该让人感到紧张，好像随时会发生什么，然后它真的发生了。同时，有时他们会播放《拯救大兵瑞恩》中的场景声音。只是为了增加一点气氛。你可以事先在理智上谈论它，但一旦枪声响起，人们尖叫呐喊，你知道，所有发生的事情，它是真实的。除了没有人死亡，没有人流血，我们可以重来。斯图说他见过新兵在这些模拟中尿裤子，甚至呕吐。这些都是对尖叫、烟雾、爆炸和这一切混乱感的正常反应。
And yet these recruits, teenagers, some of them, are going to have to make decisions in the midst of all that. Life or death decisions. Some of them, the medics, will have to deal with horrible injuries, amputations, severed arteries. For this, they use a cut suit that was invented here at Strategic Ops. Kept in a locked storage shed. So the main thing we do here is with this. Wow. The cut suit as in a suit that you cut works kind of like a fat suit. Arms go through here. So the vest goes on. Skin goes up over top.
然而，这些新兵，有些还是十几岁的孩子，将不得不在这一切之中做出决定。生死攸关的决定。其中一些医务兵将不得不处理可怕的伤害，截肢，动脉断裂。为此，他们使用了一种在这里的战略行动公司（Strategic Ops）发明的切割服。存放在一个锁着的储藏室里。所以我们在这里做的主要事情就是这个。哇。切割服，顾名思义就是你可以切割的衣服，工作原理有点像胖子装。手臂从这里穿过。背心穿上。皮肤向上覆盖。
You step into the legs. The front side goes over the top of the vest, and zips up in the back. It's a realistic looking body that you wear over your own body, and then with the help of makeup artists, inflict horrible, very realistic injuries onto. Bullet holes, shrapnel wounds, even disembowelment. Trainies can learn how to perform or assist surgery on a cut suit where the intestines are literally hanging outside the body. And for that scenario, there is something very important they need to learn.
你跨进腿部。正面覆盖在背心上方，在后面拉上拉链。这是一个看起来很逼真的身体，你穿在自己身上，然后在化妆师的帮助下，造成可怕的、非常逼真的伤害。弹孔、弹片伤，甚至内脏外露。受训者可以学习如何在内脏实际上挂在体外的切割服上进行或协助手术。对于那个场景，他们需要学习一件非常重要的事情。
And it is in the context of these very realistic combat scenarios that we will be reunited with the true star of this story, liquid ass. As a firefighter knows the smell of smoke, as a barista can sniff sour milk, surgeons know this smell. They fear it. Because this smell is a signal that something has gone wrong, that there's a tear in the intestine and feces is leaking into the abdominal cavity. No pun intended, oh shit. This is a huge infection risk.
正是在这些非常逼真的战斗场景中，我们将与这个故事的真正主角——液体屁——重逢。正如消防员知道烟味，咖啡师能闻出酸奶，外科医生也知道这种气味。他们害怕它。因为这种气味是一个信号，表明出了问题，肠道有撕裂，粪便正在渗入腹腔。没有双关语的意思，哦，该死。这是一个巨大的感染风险。
People die this way. Whatever surgery you were just doing or attempting to do, you just complicated it by 10. Strategic ops prides itself on realism, hyper realism. So they needed to recreate that oh shit moment. Show young soldiers what it would be like to encounter this in the midst of combat. There was only one smell for the job. We found a bottle of liquid ass in the makeup tent.
人们会因此死亡。无论你刚才正在做或试图做什么手术，你都让它复杂了十倍。战略行动公司以真实感、超真实感为荣。所以他们需要重现那个“哦，该死”的时刻。向年轻士兵展示在战斗中遇到这种情况会是什么样子。这项工作只有一种气味。我们在化妆帐篷里发现了一瓶液体屁。
Take it outside and sat down at a table. We'll sniff the cap. OK. In his hand, Greg holds the concoction that Alan Whitman invented in his high school bedroom. Oh, it's so bad. It's like. It's so bad.
把它带到外面，坐在桌子旁。我们闻了闻瓶盖。好的。格雷格手里拿着艾伦·惠特曼在高中卧室里发明的混合物。哦，太糟糕了。就像。太糟糕了。
So many adjectives that you can use, it's bad. Like, you know, fecal, dried, you know, nasty. If liquid asks were a person, I don't think it would be totally far fetched to call this a redemption. Because two strategic ops, this ridiculous disgusting prank product, is also indispensable. They're one of liquidats's most loyal customers. Stu says 750,000 people have trained through strategic ops. Thanks to liquidats, some of them
你可以用很多形容词，它很糟糕。就像，你知道，粪便的，干燥的，你知道，恶心的。如果液体屁是一个人，我觉得称之为救赎并不算太牵强。因为对于战略行动公司来说，这种荒谬、令人作呕的恶作剧产品也是不可或缺的。他们是液体屁最忠实的客户之一。斯图说，有75万人通过战略行动公司接受了训练。多亏了液体屁，他们中的一些人
might be better prepared to save the life of a fellow marine as he or she screams in pain amidst exploding RPGs and machine gunfire. All the while surrounded by a measmic cloud of the worst smell in the world. 99% of visible was produced this week by Amy Standing. She's the co-host and co-creator, along with Judy Campbell of the new KQD podcast, The Leap. A storytelling podcast about people making dramatic risky changes will have a link on our website.
可能在战友于爆炸的RPG和机枪扫射中痛苦尖叫时，能更好地准备好去拯救他或她的生命。同时被世界上最糟糕气味的瘴气所包围。《99%隐形》本周由艾米·斯坦丁制作。她是KQED新播客《飞跃》的联合主持人和联合创作者，另一位是朱迪·坎贝尔。《飞跃》是一个关于人们做出戏剧性、冒险性改变的故事播客，我们会在网站上提供链接。
99% Invisible is Katie Mangles, St. Greenspan, Avery Tulfman, Kurt Colessted, and me Roman Mars. Reporting from Autodesk University in Las Vegas, Nevada. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxine, the finest architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. Each member of this team is on Twitter and Instagram. I recommend you follow them all and you can find out more about this episode and listen to every single episode of 99% Invisible at 99pi.org.
《99%隐形》的团队成员有凯蒂·曼格尔斯、圣·格林斯潘、艾弗里·塔夫曼、库尔特·科尔斯泰德，还有我罗曼·马尔斯。在内华达州拉斯维加斯的欧特克大学报道。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在Arxine的办公室制作，这是加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心最好的建筑和室内设计公司。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。这个团队的每个成员都在Twitter和Instagram上。我建议你们都关注他们，你可以在99pi.org找到更多关于这一集的信息，并收听《99%隐形》的每一集。
Radio tilp you. RBI.org. Radio TBI. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
电台TBI。RBI.org。电台TBI。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。